he was inconsistent with progress in
this country when it comes to human
rights and civil rights
under originalist theory we may never
have had brown versus board of education
and the other cases i mentioned what a
loss for this great nation
that's not what we need on the court we
need people on the court who are
realists
who will look at the law and the
constitution in real terms
and not ideological terms and the notion
that this
justice is being hurried before us in
the hopes that she will eliminate the
affordable care act
in the midst of a pandemic certainly is
worth noting
it's one of the reasons one of many of
the reasons that i'll be voting no on
amy coney barrett
with her nomination to the supreme court
and i yield the floor
carolina thank you as chairman of the
judiciary committee it's my honor to
speak on the floor about this nomination
which i think is historic in
many fashions all positive from my point
of view
uh we have on before the committee the
nomination of judge barrett who
currently is on the seventh judicial
circuit
she is one of the most impressive people
i've ever met
uh two days of hearings answering every
question
thrown to her with grace and um
uh judicial demeanor i think should be
the gold standard for every other
nominee
but i want to thank my staff uh lee
holmes the director
he's done such a great job of
now the judiciary committee has done a
lot of things some some contentious some
not
but i want to thank lee for sharing this
nomination and the fine work he's done
mike forgosio that's mike i got your
first name right anyway
just outstanding you've done a terrific
job
um the permanent nominations unit for
the judiciary committee includes laura
miller raja churchill tim rodriguez
watson horner akil r-a-g-a-s
e-k-a-r don't wanna butcher your name
all of work incredibly hard for 135
article 3 judges not
not just this one uh in addition lucas
croslow joined my staff to lead the team
of specialist councils
assisting with the barrick nomination
that included sid
uh d-a-d-h-i-c-h
uh jay favel abby holstein eric palmer
robert smith
they went through the entire record
presented by judge barrett to make sure
we
would be prepared for the confirmation
process
law clerks matt simpson emily hall megan
karen and peter sengal i'd like to thank
the judiciary committee's press
secretary
taylor reed did a great job taylor along
with george hartsman
as well as by our deputy staff director
joe keeley bottom line all of them
worked really hard
you made history you should be proud you
tell your grandkids about all this
well done to my democratic colleagues i
know you didn't like what we did
but i do appreciate the way you conduct
yourself in the hearing
it wasn't a circus i think you
challenged the judge appropriately
during her time
we had four days of hearings we heard
from a variety of people about judge
barrett
in terms of the process it was well
within
what we've done in the past every
judiciary
committee markup regarding a supreme
court justice we've done the same thing
first day is opening statements two days
of
questions in the final day uh input from
outside groups and that's what we're
able to do here
so she went through the process like
every other nominee since i've been here
but let me just say this
to my democratic colleagues it's not
about the process
you find ways to make sure that most of
you can't vote for anybody we nominate
it really does break my heart
robert 78 22
that was sort of the norm i think alito
got 96 and ginsburg not
got 97. maybe i got that
the number's right i can't remember who
got what but one got 96 one got 97.
you just not to be this way senator
sullivan used to be different
we looked at the qualifications said
okay you're good to go you're a person
of integrity you're smart
you're well-rounded you're knowledgeable
in the law you may have a different
philosophy than i have
but we understand elections matter and
everybody accepted the election outcome
those days are over absolutely
completely over
destroyed there's nobody any republican
president can ever nominate
i think it's not going to face a hard
time that's too bad
that's the way it is alito 58 to 42
uh judge alito well known on our side of
the aisle the
kind of person you'd be looking at to
promote to the supreme court
when president bush nominated him
well within the mainstream robert salido
well known
in the conservative world of being very
bright
court of appeals judges that any
republican president would be looking at
to put on the court if there had ever
had an opportunity
no difference between olito and roberts
but alito went through hell
but he made it and he got 58 votes so
then along comes president obama he gets
two picks sotomayor
68 votes the 31.
i think she deserved more but 68 is
pretty darn good
i was glad to vote for her i saw that
she was qualified
then we had elena kagan 63 votes so you
can see the trend here
both of obama nominees 68-63
i thought elena kagan was highly
qualified different
judicial philosophy she was a dean of
law school at harvard but
worked for the solicitor general's
office both of them have been with the
liberal
side of the court most every case but
not all
i'm not surprised why they decided cases
i think they're
tremendously well qualified uh women
should be sitting on the court that's
exactly who you would expect a democrat
president
to pick sotomayor and kagan
so now we come back uh trump wins nobody
thought he would win
including me if i voted for somebody in
2016. i wouldn't
know if he walked through the door evan
mcmullan i think i met him once
i had my my challenge for president
trump during the 2016 primary he beat me
like a drum
i accepted my defeat i've been trying to
help him ever since and i think he's
done a really good job
of sending to the senate highly
qualified judges
he's gotten input from a lot of
different people the federalist society
you name it a lot of different people
gorsuch and kavanaugh have one thing in
common they were in my top three
recommendations
any republican president looking to
nominate somebody the supreme court
would be looking at gorsuch and
kavanaugh these are not
exotic picks they're in the mole of
sotomayor and kagan in terms of
qualifications
so what happened gorsuch was the first
attempt a partisan filibuster we had
three votes to get 60 and we couldn't
so we changed the rules for the supreme
court like
they changed the rules in 2013 for the
district court and court of appeals
if we had not gorsuch wouldn't be on the
court and to say he's not qualified is a
joke
is an insult to him and says more about
you than it does judge gorsuch
if you can't see he's qualified you
blinded by your hatred of trump
so he made it but we had to change the
rules hated to do it
but had to do it because by in any other
time gorsuch would have gotten
the same type votes as roberts because
he just highly qualified
then comes elon cavanaugh nothing about
process there there's no process
argument
right at the very end the last day of
the hearing when we thought it was all
over
you give us a letter that you'd had for
weeks
an allegation against the judge it'd be
nice to share it with him so he could
tell his side of the story
but you chose not to do that you had it
pre-cooked with the press outlets
and everything blew up so all of us on
the committee had to decide what to do i
sat down with senator flake and senator
collins and we felt like
the allegations had to be heard they're
made and i know a lot of people on our
side
thought it was unfair dirty pool but we
had
the opportunity uh to have the hearing
and the rest is history it was high
drama
uh all i can say
that something happened
to the person who accused judge keaveney
but
but i don't believe judge kavanaugh had
anything to do with it this was a party
in high school
uh dr ford couldn't remember where it
was
who was there the people that were
said to be there said they don't
remember anything like it happened
judge kavanaugh hasn't lived a life like
being described he was accused
by four or five people three of them
actually made it up
i hope some of them go to jail for lying
to the committee in the country
and uh they were trying to make him a
rapist and uh drugging women in high
school
uh and what was his annual all about
it was the most sickening episode in my
time in the senate
they were hell-bent on destroying this
guy's life based on a bunch of
manufactured lies
and evidence that wouldn't get you
wouldn't get you out of the batter's box
in any court of law in the land
and uh here we are
50-48 and
what i saw there was a turning point for
me
we cannot continue to do this you're
going to drive good people away
and i'm hoping that the barrett hearings
which were far more civil far more
traditional
will be a turning point because i don't
know who the next president will be but
there will be an opening i'm sure in the
court
i'm hoping that the next hearing is more
like barrett and less like kavanaugh
no matter who wins now barrett
i understand the concern about the
process this is the latest we've ever
confirmed somebody
you've heard all the arguments about
when the presence of one party and the
sentence of the same
of a different party you've had one
confirmation in 100 something years
that most of the time when the
presidents of the same parties the
senate
they go through i understand
the bottom line is we gave her
the same type hearing that alito
sotomayor king and gorsen kavanaugh had
my democratic colleagues showed up to
the hearing they participated they
pushed her hard
but i don't think they went across the
line they decided not to show up the
markup i hate that but that's the way it
is
i would like to spend a few minutes
talking about the person who's going on
the court in about an hour
if you're looking for somebody that a
republican would be picking
regardless of the process it would be
judge barrett
she would be on anybody's list
and i listened to senator durbin who is
a good friend and
we'll work on whatever comes our way
after the election
i find that he's somebody you can work
on hard things like immigration will
with but his description of judge
barrett simply
doesn't pass scrutiny
trying to make a character of this
person that doesn't exist
there's nothing exotic about judge
barrett
she's very mainstream in our world
uh all i can say is that after two days
of hearings the american people by 51
which is pretty hard to figure in in
this country and get 51
agreement on anything felt like she
should be going on the court
so here's what dean o'hara said
dean of notre dame law school who hired
amy barrett to be a professor at notre
dame
i have only communicated with this
august committee on two occasions
the first was ten years ago when i wrote
a strong letter in support
of now justice elena kagan
whose term as dean of harvard law school
overlapped with my own
the second is today introducing and
endorsing amy coney barrett
in equally strong terms some might find
these recommendations
to be in just a position but i find them
entirely consistent
and to anybody wondering about judge
barrett
i would highly recommend that you look
at the aba's
recommendations and the process they
used
to find her well qualified
not one person uttered a negative word
about her character according to the apa
aba someone said to the apa aba
the myth is real she is a staggering
academic mind she is incredibly honest
and forthright
she's exactly who you think she is
nothing about her is fake
she is good she's decent she's selfless
she's sincere she's an exemplary of a
living and
integrated life the standing committee
would have been hard-pressed to come up
with any conclusion
other than that judge barrett has
demonstrated professional competence
that is exceptional then they had a
committee to look at her writings
all of her writings they accepted input
from 944
people that she's interacted in in the
press professional life
not one negative comment
so forget about what politicians say
about judge barrett
forget about what people who don't
recognize president trump as being a
legitimate president say about judge
barrett
forget about what i say if you want to
look at what people who
work with her said that are in the law
business that know her individually
have worked with her as a judge as a
professor
and they conclude without any doubt she
is one of the most gifted people to ever
be nominated to the supreme court
there's nothing exotic about judge
barrett
she's going on to the court in about an
hour that's exactly where she needs to
be
she's the type person who's lived a life
worthy of being nominated
she's the type person that's worthy of
receiving a large vote in the senate but
she won't get it
she's not going to get one democratic
vote and you're right after the process
if you want to that's fine but what
about the others
all i can say is that we're going to
have an election here in about a week
and whatever happens i'm going to
acknowledge
the winner when it's all said and done
it may go to the supreme court i don't
know
but there'll be a day that we know who
won
and i'm going to accept those results
and i'm going to do with the next
president what i've tried to do with
this one and every other one
try to find a way forward on things that
are hard
keep the country moving forward so
to the majority leader and the minority
leader
um tough place around here now
this too shall pass but this is about
judge barrett this is about her time
her moment she's done everything you
would expect
of her she's exceeded every
challenge put in her way she's impressed
everybody she's worked with she has
impressed
the country she's going onto the court
because that's where she deserves to be
as to us in the senate
maybe down the road we can get back to
the way
we used to be i don't know but i do know
this
there's nothing exotic about judge
barrett
she's as mainstream as it gets from our
side of the aisle and when it comes to
people outside of politics looking at
her
it was universal highly qualified highly
competent
ready to serve this country the
socialist justice of the supreme court
and my last thought it's hard to be
a conservative person of color
that is a very difficult road to hoe in
a modern american politics
my uh good friend tim scott is a great
voice for conservatism and uh tim
a lot of things said about tim it said
about nobody else on our side of the
aisle
and he's tough he can handle it same for
conservative women
judge barrett did not abandon her faith
she embraces it but she said i embrace
my faith but as a judge it will not be
the
rule of amy it will be the rule of law
it will be the facts
it will be the law and outcome dictated
by the law not by anything i personally
believe
but i will say this for the young
conservative women out there
for pro-life and embrace your faith
there is a seat at the table for you
this is historic
this nomination is different this is a
breakthrough
for conservative young women and i was
honored to be the chairman of the
committee
they reported out judge barrett to the
floor of the senate
and i'm going to be honored to cast my
vote to put her on the supreme court
exactly where she deserves to be i yield
mr president minority leader today
monday october 26 2020
will go down as one of the darkest days
in the 231 year history of the united
states senate
let the record show that tonight
the republican senate majority decided
to thwart the will of the people
and confirm a lifetime appointment to
the supreme court
in the middle of a presidential election
after more than 60 million americans
have voted
let the record show that tonight
the republican majority will break 231
years of precedent
and become the first majority to confirm
a supreme court justice
this close to election day and let the
record show
that tonight the republican majority
will make a mockery
of its own stated principle that the
american people deserve a voice in the
selection of supreme court justices
completing the partisan theft of two
seats
on the supreme court using completely
contradictory rationales and let the
record show
that the american people their lives and
rights and freedoms
will suffer the consequences of this
nomination
for a generation this entire debate
can be summed up in three lies
propagated by the republican majority
and one great terrible truth
the first lie is that the republican
majority is being consistent in
following its own standard
what rubbish after refusing a democratic
nominee to the supreme court because an
election was eight months away
they will confirm a republican nominee
before an election that is eight
days away
what's leader mcconnell's excuse
he claims that the principle of not
confirming justices in presidential
years
only applies when there's divided
government
but this is what leader mcconnell said
after justice scalia died
the american people should have a voice
in the selection
of their next supreme court justice
that's all he said he didn't say that
the american people should have a voice
but only when there's divided government
no
the last bit is exposed facto
if this were really about divided
government all along
republican senators would not have
promised on the record to follow their
own standard if the situation
was reversed i want to use my i want you
to use my words against me said
the chairman of the judiciary committee
if there's a republican president in
2016 and a vacancy occurs in the last
year of the first term
you can say lindsey graham said let the
next president
whoever it might be make that nomination
so the claim by the leader
that this is consistent with their own
principle
please rather than accept the
consequences of its own words and deeds
the republican majority is lighting its
credibility on fire
this hypocritical 180 degree turn
is spectacularly obvious to the american
people
the second lie is that the republican
majority is justified
because of democratic actions on
judicial nominations in the past
the republican leader claims that his
majority's actions are justified by all
the bad things democrats did years ago
he claims that every escalation of
significance
in judicial debates was made by
democrats
but in his tortured convoluted history
lesson
leader mcconnell left out a whole bunch
of chapters
he omitted that republicans bottled up
more than 60 judicial nominees by
president clinton
refusing them even a hearing he made no
reference to the decision by republican
senators to hold open 14 appellate court
seats
in the 1990s so that a republican
president could fill them
instead a tactic republicans would
revisit under president obama
when republicans used partisan
filibusters
to block his nominees to the d.c circuit
at the time republican senators
including my colleague from kentucky
amazingly
accused president obama of trying to
pack the court by the mere act of
nominating judges to vacancies of the
second circuit
what a hypocritical double standard
which appears to be endemic
in leader mcconnell's recounting of
history
and on top of it all the leader has
asked the senate to play a blame game
that dates all the way back to 1980
1987 pointing to a three-minute speech
by senator kennedy about robert bork as
the original sin
in the judicial wars seriously
that's what he said because one democrat
gave one
three-minute speech that republicans
didn't like
leader mcconnell can steamroll the
minority to confirm
a justice in the middle of election
imagine
trying to explain to someone sorry i
have to burn down your house
because of something one of your friends
said about one of my friends 33 years
ago
that's how absurd and obnoxious this
game has gotten
that's how unjustifiable the majority's
actions are
how flimsy their excuses have become
the leader's final argument boils down
to
but you started it a declaration you'd
sooner hear on this
in the school yard and on the floor of
the united states
senate and the third and the perhaps the
greatest lie
is that the republican majority is
confirming judge barrett
solely on the basis of her
qualifications
not based on her views on the issues
my colleagues insist that judge barrett
should be confirmed on her credentials
alone
that's all they talk about they don't
talk about her views on the issues
only qualifications well this canard
is about as apparent as a glass door
everyone can see right through it what's
the real reason republicans are so
desperate to rush judge barrett on to
the supreme court of course it's not
because of her qualifications
if my republican friends truly believed
that the only thing that mattered about
a judicial candidate is their
qualifications
then merrick garland would be sitting on
the supreme
court right now if the republican leader
truly believed that judicial
appointments were about qualifications
and qualifications alone judge garland
would be justice garland right now
judge garland was among the most
qualified candidates
ever ever to be nominated to the supreme
court
no republican senator has disputed that
but they didn't want judge garland on
the bench they do want judge barrett
they subjected judge garland to an
unprecedented partisan blockade
but they're erecting a monument to
hypocrisy
to rush judge barrett onto the bench why
it's not because she's more qualified
than just judge garland was
what's the difference between barrett
and garland
the difference is not qualifications but
views
we know that we all know that
health care a woman's rights a woman's
right to choose gun safety you name it
it's not because the far right wants
judge barrett's views on the court
but it's because the far right wants
judge barrett's views on the court
but not judge garland's the truth is
this nomination is part of a
decades-long effort to tilt the
judiciary to the far right
to accomplish through the courts what
what
the radical right in their allies senate
republicans
could never accomplish through congress
senate republicans failed to repeal the
affordable care act
so president trump and republican
attorneys general are suing to eliminate
the law in court
republicans would never dare to attempt
to repeal
roe v wade in congress
so they pass onerous laws in state
legislatures
that they control to drive the right to
point
to drive that right to the point of near
extinction and then provoke
the supreme court to review roe v wade
the far right has never held the
majority on the court to limit roe v
wade or griswold
but if judge barrett becomes justice
barrett it very well might
and if you're looking for some hard
numbers to prove
that that the political right considers
ideology and not just qualifications
consider this under justice roberts
there have been 80 cases
80 decided by a five to four majority
in which the five justices nominated by
republican presidents came down on one
side
and the four justices nominated by
democratic presidents
came down on the other eighty cases
exactly the same majority calling balls
and strikes
and an amazing coincidence all the
republican nominations
nominated justices think it's a strike
and all the democratic ones think it's a
ball
or vice versa it would be the most
remarkable coincidence
in the history of mathematics if nine
justices
simply calling balls and strikes
exhibited the
same split in the exact same
configuration
80 times we all know what the game is
here
so stop pretending stop pretending there
aren't entire organizations
dedicated to advancing far-right judges
stop pretending that the political right
doesn't spend
millions of dollars to prop up the
far-right federalist society
and support certain judicial candidates
because they only want
qualified judges no
they want to systematically and
permanently tilt the courts
to the far right so does judge barrett
have views on legal issues
you bet she does and that
brings me to the one great and terrible
truth
about this nomination the american
people
will suffer the consequences of judge
barrett's far right
out of the mainstream views for
generations judge barrett came before
the judiciary committee
and refused to answer nearly any
question of substance
that's the new game at the hearings she
would not answer questions about health
care
she would not say whether voter
intimidation is illegal
she would not say if she thought
medicare and social security were
constitutional
she could not even offer platitudes in
responses to questions about the
peaceful transfer of power
and refused to say if climate change was
real
it's not because judge barrett isn't
allowed to answer these questions
it's because she knows how unfavorable
her views on the issues
might sound to the american people
but the thing is we do know how judge
barrett thinks
she views certain rights like the right
to privacy
through a pinhole she was closely
affiliated with organizations who
advocated the outright repeal
of roe v wade but she views other rights
like the right to keep and bear arms as
almost infinitely expansive
she once authored a dissent arguing the
federal government does not
have the authority to ban all felons
felons
from owning guns only a few hours ago
the republican senator from missouri
proudly declared from the senate floor
that judge barrett is the most openly
pro-life judicial nominee
to the supreme court in his lifetime
quote this is an individual he said of
judge barrett
who has been open in her criticism of
that illegitimate decision
roe v wade he was being more honest
than most of the talk around here which
says it's only about qualifications
judge barrett has
proudly fashioned herself in the mold of
her mentor
justice scalia who before his death
appeared set to declare union fees to be
unconstitutional
driving a stake into the heart of
american
the american labor movement while
american workers break their back to
make ends meet
and earn ever less of an evergr of
ever-growing corporate profits
what might justice scalia's former clerk
portend for the future of labor rights
what about voting rights
judge barrett has suggested that certain
rights are civic rights
including voting rights and can can be
restrained by the government
but other rights like the right to keep
and bear arms are individual rights
that cannot be subject to even the most
common sense restrictions
and of course what about health care
judge barrett has argued that justice
roberts got it wrong
when he upheld the affordable care act
she said that if justice roberts read
the statute properly
the supreme court would have had to
invalidate her words
the law that's the same thing
by the way that donald trump said about
justice roberts
and the aca that's the great and
terrible truth
about this nomination judge barrett
holds far-right views
well outside the american mainstream and
those views
matter to the vast majority
of americans they matter
to women facing the hardest decision
of their lives they matter to lbgtq
americans like my daughter
who only five years ago won the legal
right to marry who she loves
and could lose it just as fast they
matter to little girls like
seven-year-old penny feinman from west
hempstead long island
born with a neurological desire disorder
bound to a wheelchair attached to a
feeding tube
who is alive today alive today
because of the affordable care act we're
talking about the rights and freedoms of
the american people
their right to affordable health care to
make private medical decisions with
their doctors
to join a union to vote without
impediment to marry who they love and
not be fired because of who they are
judge amy coney barrett will decide
whether all those rights will be
sustained
or be curtailed for generations
and based on her views on the issues not
on her qualifications
but her views on the issues judge
barrett
puts every single one of those
fundamental rights
american rights at risk
so i want to be clear with the american
people
the senate majority is this republican
senate majority
is breaking faith with you
doing the exact opposite of what it
promised four years ago
because they wish to cement a majority
on the supreme court that threatens your
fundamental rights
and i want to be very clear with my
republican colleagues
you may win this vote and amy coney
barrett
may become the next associate justice of
the supreme court
but you will never never get your
credibility back
and the next time the american people
give democrats a majority in this
chamber
you will have forfeited the right
to tell us how to run that majority
you may win this vote but in the process
you will speed the precipitous decline
of faith
in our institution our politics the
senate
and the supreme court you will give an
already divided and angry nation
a fresh outrage and open a wound in this
chamber
that will take a very long time to heal
you walk a perilous road
i know that you think that this will
eventually blow over
but you're wrong the american people
will never forget
this blatant act of bad faith
they will never forget your complete
disregard for their voices
for the people standing online right now
and voting
their choice not your choice
they will never forget the lack
of consistency honor
decency fairness
and principle they will never forget
the rights that are limited constrained
or taken away
by a far-right majority on the supreme
court and history
will record that by brute political
force
in contradiction to its stated
principles
this republican majority confirmed a
lifetime
appointment on the eve of an election
a justice who will alter the lives and
freedoms of the american people
while they stood in line to vote
leader mcconnell has lectured the senate
before
on consequences of the majority's action
you'll regret this he told democrats
once
and you may regret it this a lot sooner
than you think
listen to those words you'll regret this
and you may regret it a lot sooner than
you think
i would change just one word my
colleagues may regret this
for a lot longer than they think
here at this late hour
at the end of this sordid chapter in the
history of the senate
the history of the supreme court my
deepest and greatest sadness
is for the american people generations
yet unborn
will suffer the consequences of this
nomination
as the globe gets warmer as workers
continue to fall behind
as unlimited dark money floods our
politics
as reactionary state legislatures
curtail a woman's right to choose
gerrymander districts and limit the
rights of minorities to vote
my deepest greatest and most abiding
sadness tonight
is for the american people and what this
nomination
will mean for their lives
their freedoms their fundamental rights
monday october 26 2020
it will go down as one of the darkest
days
in the 231 year history of the united
states
senate i yield the floor
mr president majority leader
i think my remarks may encroach somewhat
on the time
previously set for beginning the vote i
asked consent that i'd be allowed to
finish
without objection
well this evening the senate will render
one of the most
consequential judgments
it can ever deliver
we will approve a lifetime appointment
to our nation's
highest court
since the int dried on the constitution
only 114 men and women have been
entrusted
to uphold the separation of powers
protect people's rights and dispense
impartial justice
on the supreme court
in a few minutes judge amy coney
barrett of indiana will join their ranks
this body has spent weeks studying the
nominee's record
we've examined 15 years of scholarly
writings
about 100 opinions from the 7th circuit
and testimonials from legal experts
running the gamut
from close colleagues to total strangers
there have been one-on-one meetings for
every senator who wanted one
and a week of intensive hearings
all of it all of it has pointed
to one conclusion
this is one of the most brilliant
admired and well-qualified
qualified nominees in our lifetime
intellectually judge barrett is an
absolute
all-star she graduated number one in her
class
at notre dame law school she clerked on
the second highest federal court
and the supreme court then she returned
to her alma mater and became an
award-winning
academic judge barrett's
mastery of the constitution
gives her a firm grasp
on the judicial role
she's pledged to apply the law as
written
really well somehow
everyone knows in advance that
nominations like bork
thomas alito gorsuch kavanaugh and
barrett are certain to whip up national
frenzies
while nominations like ginsburg briar
sotomayor and kagan
are just calm events by comparison
this glaring asymmetry predates our
recent disputes
and it comes my colleagues from a
fundamental disagreement on the role of
a judge in our republic
we just have a fundamental difference of
opinion
we just heard the democratic leader name
all of these things that are threatened
by this nominee
sound very similar to the tunes we've
heard before
well we like many americans want judges
to fulfill the limited role the
constitution assigns to them
stick to text resolve cases impartially
and leave policy making to the people
and their representatives which is what
we do here
we just spent four years confirming
brilliant qualified constitutionalists
to the supreme court and lower courts
who understand their roles
53 circuit judges
over 200 judges in total and we're about
to
confirm the third supreme court justice
what they all have in common
brilliant smart and know what a judge is
supposed to be
but the left thanks the framers of our
country got this all wrong
they botched the job the people who
wrote the constitution
didn't understand what a judge ought to
be
several senate democrats have reaffirmed
in recent days during this discussion
they actually find it quaint
or naive to think
a judge would simply follow the law
quaint or naive
scalia used to say if you want to make
policy why you run for office
that's not what we do here
gorsuch said we don't wear red robes or
blue robes or wear
black robes
what they want is activist judges
they've made it quite clear
the democratic leader just a few minutes
ago made it quite clear
so what they're looking for is a small
panel of lawyers with elite educations
to reason backward from outcomes and
enlighten all the rest of us
enlighten all the rest of us with their
moral
and political judgment
whether the constitution speaks
to the issue or not
they know best what's for us
no matter what the constitution
or the law may say
and you know for the last several
decades in many cases that's what
they've gotten
one activist decision after another
giving the subjective preferences
of one side the force of law
across a variety variety of social moral
and policy matters like a healthy
society would
lead to democratic debate the personal
opinion of judges have superseded
the will of the people now they call
that a success
and they want more of it
president obama actually was
refreshingly
honest about this he said he wanted to
appoint judges who had
empathy well think about that for a
minute colleagues
what if you're the litigant before the
judge
for whom the judge does not have empathy
you're in tough shape you're in tough
shape
so you give them credit for being pretty
honest about this
that's what they're looking for
the smartest leftish
people they can put to make all the
decisions for the rest of us
rather than leaving it to the messy
democratic process to sort these things
out
the way the framers intended
and that is why it's clearly why we've
taken on such an
outsized
combative atmosphere
with regard to these confirmations
that's why they've become so contentious
because they want to control not only
the legislative body but the judicial
decisions as well
let me just say this there's nothing
innate about legal training that equips
people to be moral philosophers
there's just nothing inherent in legal
training
that equips people to be moral
philosophers
and incidentally as i just said that's
why these
confirmations have taken on such an
outsize
unhealthy significance the remarks we
just heard from across the aisle show
exactly why the framers wanted to stop
the courts from becoming clumsy
indirect battlefields for subjective
debates
that belong in this chamber and over in
the house
and in state legislatures around the
country
the left does not rage and panic at
every constitutional judge because they
will simply enact
our party's policy preferences
any number of recent rulings make that
very clear
the problem that every judicial seat
occupied by a constitutionalist
is one fewer opportunity for the left
to go on offense for the left to go on
offense
at the end of the day this is a valid
debate
the difference of opinion on the
judicial role is something the senate
and our system
are built to handle
but there's something else colleagues
our system cannot
bear as you've heard tonight we now have
one political faction
essentially claiming they now see
legitimate defeat as an oxymoron
they now see legitimate defeat
as an oxymoron
our colleagues cannot point to a single
senate rule that's been broken
not one
they made one false claim about
committee procedure which the
parliamentarian dismissed
the process comports entirely with the
constitution
we don't have any doubt do we that if
the shoe was on the other foot they'd be
confirming
this nominee and have no doubt
if the shoe was on the other foot in
2016 they'd have done the same thing
why because they had the elections
that made those decisions possible the
reason we were able to make the decision
we did in 2016 is because we'd become
the majority in 2014.
the reason we were able to do what we
did in 2016 2018 and 2020 is because
we had the majority
no rules were broken whatsoever
so all of these outlandish claims
are utterly absurd and the louder they
scream
the more inaccurate they are you can
always tell that just
check the decibel level on the other
side
the higher it goes up the less accurate
they are
our democratic colleagues keep repeating
the word illegitimate
as if repetition would make it true
you just say it often enough does it
make it true i don't think so
we're a constitutional republic
legitimacy does not flow
from their feelings
you know legitimacy is not the result of
how they feel about it
you know you can't win them all and
elections have consequences
and what this administration and this
republican senate has done
is exercised the power that was given to
us by the american people
in a manner that is entirely represent
within
the rules of the senate and the
constitution of the united states
irony indeed
think about how many times our
democratic friends have said
been berating president trump for
allegedly refusing to accept legitimate
outcomes he does not like
how many times have we heard that
president trump won't accept
outcomes he does not like well they're
flunking that very test right before our
eyes
that's their problem they don't like the
outcome
well the reason this outcome came about
is because we had a series of successful
elections
one of our two major political parties
increasingly claims that
any any political system that deals them
a setback is somehow illegitimate
and this started actually long before
this vacancy
as we all know one year ago senate
democrats sent the court
the court directly
an amicus brief that read like a note
from a gangster film
they wrote the supreme court is not well
in their amicus free the supreme court
is not well
perhaps the court can heal itself
heal itself before the public demands it
be
restructured restructured
in march of this year the democratic
leader stood outside the court went over
in front of the court
and threatened multiple justices by name
here's what he said you won't know what
hit you
if you go forward with these awful
decisions you will pay the price
that the democratic leader of the senate
in front of the supreme court
mentioning justices by name and in
effect saying
if you rule the wrong way
bad things are going to happen
for multiple years now democrats in this
body and on the presidential campaign
stump
have sought to revive the discredited
concept
of court hacking
every high school student in america
learns about franklin roosevelt's
unprincipled assault on judicial
independence
so now they're thinking about repeating
it
former vice president biden who spent
decades
the idea here in the senate obediently
says he'll look into it
most importantly the late ruth
vader ginsburg said last year
last year when i asked about this she
said nine is the right number
that's the vacancy we're feeling right
now
i don't think any of them have quoted
her on this issue lately have you
ruth bader ginberg ginsburg said nine is
the right number
these latest threats followed decades of
subtler attempts to take
independent judges and essentially put
them on political probation
you don't rule the way i want
something dire might happen how many
consecutive nominees have democrats and
the media would
insisted would quote tip
the balance of the court how often do we
hear that
tip the balance of the court
has anyone tallied up how many hard
right turns
the courts have supposedly taken in our
lifetimes
all this ominous talk is a transparent
attempt to apply
improper pressure to impartial judges
rule how we want or we're coming after
the court
rule how we want or we're coming after
the court
vote how we want
or we'll destroy the senate
by adding new states
these have been the democratic demands
this is not about separation of powers
it's a hostage situation a hostage
situation
elections come and go political power is
never
permanent but the consequences could be
cataclysmic
if our colleagues across the aisle let
partisan passions boil
over and scorch scorch the ground rules
of our government the framers built the
senate
to be the nation's firewall over
and over this institution
our institution has stood up to stop
recklessness
that could have damaged our country
forever
so tonight colleagues were called on to
do that again
tonight we can place a woman of
unparalleled ability and temperament on
the supreme court
we can take another historic step toward
a judiciary that fulfills
its role with excellence
but does not grasp after power that our
constitutional
system intentionally assigns somewhere
else
and we can stand loud and clear that the
united states senate does not
bow to intemperate threats
voting to confirm this nominee should
make every
single senator
proud so i urge my colleagues
to do just that
clerk will call the roll mr alexander
president ms baldwin
mr barrasso
uh a quorum is present
uh can i read all
all post-cloture time has expired the
question occurs on the nomination of amy
coney barrett
of indiana to be associate justice of
the supreme court of the united states
a senator
is there a sufficient second there is a
sufficient second
the clerk will call the roll mr
alexander
miss baldwin mr barrasso
mr bennett mrs blackburn
mr blumenthal mr blunt
mr booker mr bozeman
mr braun mr brown
mr burr ms cantwell
mrs capito mr cardin
mr carper mr casey
mr cassidy miss collins
mr coons mr cornyn
miss cortes masto
mr cotton mr kramer
mr crapo mr cruz
mr danes ms duckworth
mr durbin
mr enzi ms ernst
mrs feinstein
mrs fisher mr gardner
mrs gillibram mr graham
mr grassley hi miss harris
miss hassan mr hawley
mr heinrich miss hirono
mr hoeven
mrs hyde smith mr rainhoff
mr johnson mr jones
mr kane
mr kennedy
mr king miss klobuchar mr lankford
mr leahy
mr lee hi mrs leffler
mr mansion mr markey
mr mcconnell
ms mcsally mr menendez
mr merkley
mr moran ms markowski
mr murphy mrs murray
mr paul mr purdue
mr peters
mr portman mr reed
mr risch mr roberts
mr romney mr rosen
mr rounds mr rubio
mr sanders
mr sass mr schatz
mr schumer mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina
mrs shaheen mr shelby
miss cinema ms smith miss stavenow
mr sullivan
mr tester mr thune
mr tillis
mr toomey mr udall
mr van hollen
mr warner
miss warren mr whitehouse
mr waker
mr wyden
mr young
senators voting in the affirmative
alexander barrasso blackburn
blunt bozeman braun
burr capitol cassidy
cornyn cotton cramer crapo
cruz danes enzi
ernst fisher gardner
graham grassley holly
hoeven hyde smith inhofe
johnson kennedy lankford
lee leffler mcconnell mcsally
moran murkowski hall
purdue portman risch
roberts romney rounds
rubio sas scott of florida
scott of south carolina shelby sullivan
boone tillis toomey
wicker young
senators voting in the negative
baldwin blumenthal booker
brown cantwell cardin
carper casey collins
coons cortez masto duckworth
durbin feinstein gillibrand
harris hassan heinrich
hirono kane king
klobuchar leahy manchin
marky merkley murphy
murray peters rosen
sanders schumer shaheen
cinema smith van hollen
warner warren whitehouse
wyden mr menendez
mr menendez no mr schatz mr schatz
no
mr reed mr reed now
stabilo miss stabbing out no
mr bennett mr bennett no
mr jones mr jones
no
you
uh
mr udall mr udall
no
it will come to order are there any
senators in the chamber who wish to vote
or
change their vote if not on this vote
the a's are 52 the nays are 48
the nomination of amy coney barrett of
indiana
to be an associate justice of the
supreme court of the united states
is confirmed
i moved to proceed to legislative
session
question is on the motion all in favor
say aye
aye allah's no the eyes appear to have
it
the eyes do have it the motion is agreed
to i'll move to proceed to executive
session to consider calendar number 865
the question is on the motion all in
favor say aye
aye all opposed say nay
the eyes appear to have it the eyes do
have it the motion
is agreed to the clerk will report the
nomination
nomination the judiciary james ray nept
ii
of ohio to be united states district
judge for the northern district of ohio
i'll send a closure motion to the desk
clerk will report the motion closure
motion we the underscience senators in
accordance with the provisions of rule
22 of the standing rules of the senate
do hereby move to brand new closed
debate on the nomination of james ray
neph ii of ohio to be united states
district judge
for the northern district of ohio signed
by 17 senators as
follows i was consent to reading the
knightsby way
without objection
i just consent to mandatory quorum call
be waived without objection
i suggest the atoms of corn